hello in this module i'm going to first
show you how minimizing the average
error on your training examples can
actually lead to disparities between a
performance between groups
and then i'm going to show you a simple
approach called group distribution and
robust optimization that can mitigate
some of these disparities
so let me begin with a very famous
example of disparities or inequalities
in machine learning it's called the
gender shades project in this project
the authors collected a data set of
images and faces of different
genders and different
skin tones
and then they evaluated a gender
classifier from microsoft face plus plus
in ibm
what they found was rather striking so
for a group of lighter skinned males
the classifier was almost perfect
but if you look at the performance of
those classifiers on darker skinned
females you'll see that the accuracy are
much much worse
so this is a general problem in machine
learning which is that inequalities
between different groups arise because
machine learning is generally
where you minimize the average loss
so these
inequalities can have real world
consequences
so in this vivid case a black man was
wrongly arrested due to an incorrect
match with another black man captured
from a surveillance video and this
mistake was due to a mistake made by a
facial recognition system
so
given what we just saw on the generous
age project we can see that lower
accuracies for some groups might lead to
more false arrests which adds to already
problematic inequalities that
exist in our society today
so in this module i'm going to focus on
this issue of performance disparities
between groups and how we might be able
to mitigate them
but i also want to highlight that even
if we didn't have any disparities
between groups there's a question of
whether facial recognition technology
should be used in law enforcement or in
surveillance or anything at all
and these are big thorny ethical
questions which we're not going to
unfortunately be able to spend much time
with in this module but i just want to
highlight that it's important to
remember that sometimes
the issue is not with the solution but
in the framing of the problem itself
so
general shades was an example of
classification but to make things
simpler let us consider our friend
linear regression
so recall in linear aggression we start
with a training
set which consists of examples each
example has an input x and output y
and but in our case we're going to
assume each example is also annotated
with a group g
um so we're going to have a
set of let's plot this over here so
here's 1 4.
and here's a second example 2 8 which is
up here
um and then
these examples down here are going to
come from group b so we're going to have
two groups a and b
and here
they are over here
okay so the goal of machine learning or
linear regression in particular is to
produce a predictor
such as this one
and the predictor is going to take new
inputs such as 3 and produce an output
such as 3.27
so
in linear regression um we assume that
the predictor
has the form um a weight vector dot
a feature vector v of x
in the simple example we're going to
restrict ourselves to the case where the
the feature vector is simply the
identity map just x
which gives us a hypothesis class which
is the set of all lines that go through
the origin
so you can think about sweeping lines
through the origin here
and the white vector is just going to be
a single number uh w
so already you can see some tension here
so which web vector would you choose
would you choose one that's closer to
these
points in group b
or in group a and this tension means
that we have to compromise somehow and
exactly how we compromise is going to
have some
implications
so notice also that the predictor
doesn't use the group information it
just takes an input x as before
what's going to use group information is
the learning algorithm and we'll get to
that a little bit later
so um just as a review
for linear regression we define the loss
function of an input x y
um and a particular wave vector to be
the simply the difference between the
predicted value of that classifier or
sorry progressive
f of w
and the target value
y squared
and uh remember that we defined the
training loss of a particular wave
vector as follows it's going to be the
average so one over a number of training
examples over some over training
examples of the per example loss
so visually we can
see this on this plot where for each
value of w
in our case here remember w is a scalar
for this particular example we get a
loss value
so this is the training loss which is
this
this curve here
and um
what we can do is let's practice
evaluating this training loss at a
particular value of w let's say one so
this is going to take the average over
this data set
and it's going to return some value
7.5
okay so the loss of
the average loss
at w equals 1 is 7.5
so
um which seems okay but now let's
remember let's pure a little bit closer
at how
the loss is spread across groups okay so
we're going to define
a notion of a per-group loss so here's
our training set so for group a what is
this loss in group b group b what's this
loss so formally we're going to define
the per group loss written train loss
sub g for group g
g can be either a or b
to be the average now over only those
examples in that group so this notation
d train of g is the set of examples in
group g
and of the for example loss again
okay so um we're gonna plot these two
losses on this uh curve here and we see
that um
we have
um these two plots so
train loss a looks like this and train
loss b looks like that
and we can practice evaluating um these
different loss functions at our uh
example weight vector one here so train
loss a is going to be an average
remember only over the examples in group
a
and that's going to give us 22.5
you can see
it looks like about 22.5 here
and then what about b
so b actually gets a loss of zero
which you can see at this point
so you can see that we have a single
wave vector
one
gets very different losses on the two
data sets
on the two groups a is doing a lot worse
it has 22.5 and b is doing
much better it has a zero which is the
minimum loss you can hope for
so this is an example of a disparity
between
if we were to choose wave vector one
there would be a huge disparity between
the performance on
these two groups
so um
so we can look at the losses of
different groups but it'll be helpful to
kind of summarize that as a single
number
now we're going to capture by by a
quantity called the maximum group loss
and you might guess from the name that
the maximum group loss written train
loss max
is simply just going to be the maximum
over all groups of the per group loss
and so visually what this looks like is
as follows
so let me
um so remember we had um in
in yellow here um
or orange the
loss
of group a
and in blue we have the loss of group b
and the maximum group loss is this
function of w as the other functions
which is going to be the pointwise
maximum so at every point we choose
either
the value of
that's loss of a or b that's going to be
larger so as you can see it traces out
an upper envelope here um over here it's
uh the loss of a
is higher so it's going to track that
and over here the loss of b is higher so
it kind of
hugs b from there on
okay so um let's evaluate our at our
point um w equals one
we see that remember from the previous
slide that the two losses are of our
22.5 and zero for the two groups
um and then to compute the
maximum we just take the max of these
two values and you get 22.5 so 22.5 is a
single number that summarizes how
bad is the worst group of and the max
what's the maximum group loss
and if you compare the maximum group
loss 22.5 with the average loss which is
7.5
you'll see that the maximum group loss
is
larger and it's always larger
so now let's uh compare these two loss
functions we have the average
loss
and the maximum group loss so we can
plot both of these
here
and
[Music]
what
pictorially we can see what's what's
going on
so uh here let me just plot our
data points just so we have them
available
um
so these functions are definitely very
different
okay so what happens now when we try to
minimize the average loss versus the
maximum group loss so let's start with
minimizing the average slot so this is
standard learning
this is a status quo you find the
minimum of the average loss which is
going to be
this point w equals
1.09 it gets a loss of 7.29
so it looks like you're doing pretty
well but if you remember look at the
worst group loss of that wave vector
then we'll see that it's above 20 which
is not great
so what you can do instead
is to do what we call group
distributionally robust optimization
or group dro which is simply going to
minimize the maximum group loss so it's
going to minimize this purple
plot here
and what happens when you do that you
get w equals 1.58
which gets a loss of 15.69 which is
better than the 20 plus that you work on
there
now of course the average loss is
worsened
because at this point the average loss
on the on the red curve is a little bit
higher so there's a trade-off here
and we can see this tension kind of play
out over on this this plot over here
so here we see that if you were to
minimize the average loss what you would
do is find a regressor or a model that's
um very close to the points over here b
because there's four of them they're
kind of the majority class dominates
whereas if you minimize the maximum
group loss then you're going to get this
purple line which is going to be able to
balance out the two groups
no matter how many points are over here
versus over here so you can think about
this the purple line is more fair
because it treats groups more
equally
so how do we
minimize the maximum grip loss
so
as before we're going to use gradient
descent and follow our nose
so what this looks like let me just
should i plot this
so here's the objective function the
maximum group loss is train loss max is
remember the maximum over all the groups
of um
trained the per group training loss
and so
how do you take the gradient of of a max
well the grading of a max
remember is equal to the gradient
of the function where we're evaluating
at
the particular
value of g g star and what is g star g
star is the arg max
over the training loss
so
um
let's look at this picture so basically
what we're doing so we want to diff uh
take the gradient of this purple curve
right
and so if you're over here the gradient
of the purple curve is exactly the
gradient of
the
the loss on group a
and if you're over here
the grading of the the
maximum group loss is exactly
the gradient of
group b and it's exactly coin's response
to g star is a over here because group a
is worse and g star is b over here
because group b is worse
so
to compute the gradient it's actually
kind of very simple you first just
evaluate
at your current um
weight vector
what are the losses of the different
groups
and you look at the group that is
hurting the most has the highest loss
and then you just update um on those
examples
so it's a very intuitive process you
find which group needs the most amount
of help and then you only um update your
parameters based on that group
so one note is that it's important that
we're talking about gradient descent
not sarcastic descent because the cancer
gradient descent relies on the objective
function being a sum over terms but this
is a maximum over
a sum
so it exactly won't work um how did
exactly get stochastic methods to work
properly is beyond the scope of
this module but you can read the notes
for pointers
okay so let me summarize here so we've
introduced the setting where examples
are associated with groups we've done a
free regression but this generalizes for
classification and they're more general
machine learning problems
we saw that we have the average loss
and the maximum group loss and these are
different what is good on average is not
going to be a group for
all groups
and we see that there's always a tension
between
the groups if the groups are pulling you
in kind of different directions
and we saw that group distributionally
robust optimization or group dro is a
very simple algorithm that minimizes the
maximum group loss
the the purple curve over here
and finally i want to remark that um
this module has kept things simple but
there's many many more nuances so
intersectionality is this principle or a
property where
you on a group such as you know white
women is actually made out of multiple
attributes and these groups might behave
differently than the more coarse groups
the women or
um
the the set of white people
and
so we have to kind of take into account
um you know finer green groups
there are also cases where we don't
might not know what the groups are maybe
we don't collect demographic information
and we have to infer them
there's also an issue with overfitting
we're talking only about the training
loss here just for simplicity but of
course what we care about in machine
learning is doing well on um out of
a test set
um but we're not talking about the test
set here so there's many more references
in the notes and i hope this has piqued
your interest and
realizing that inequality is should be
considered a first-class citizen when we
think about machine learning methods
so that's it thank you